- At President Trump's inauguration,
he spoke of American carnage.
Well, he delivered.
There is apparently nothing
that President Trump cannot defile.
As you probably know, a right wing,
Trump-supporting violent mob
breached the U.S. Capitol.
They broke windows, they blew past police,
and they stormed both
chambers of Congress.
They wore American flags
and were apparently incapable of irony.
I remember I visited Congress
when I was in high school.
The Capitol is a building
that oozes history.
And unfortunately we
are witnessing a history
of a different kind.
In the Civil War, the Confederates
only made it as far as Fort Sumner.
Yet today, a Confederate flag
flew inside the U.S. Capitol.
And today, riders
lowered the American flag
to instead fly a Trump flag.
And throughout it all, like
Nero playing his fiddle
while Rome burned, Trump sat
back and watched cable news.
And apparently Trump actually
basks in this mayhem,
saying on Twitter, "These
are the things and events
that happen when a sacred
landslide election victory
is so unceremoniously and
viciously stripped away
from great patriots who have been badly
and unfairly treated for so long."
In reality, this is the most direct attack
on our Capitol since 1814.
And they have delayed the certification
of our democratic process.
It's hard for me to even think
of a worse scenario for our democracy.
The president and his supporters
have made the United
States a laughingstock.
Now, I'll compile my thoughts
and do a full video on
whether the president and his supporters
have committed incitement,
sedition, and treason.
But apart from these legal technicalities,
we know who was responsible for today.
As the president was on his
dais, he incited the mob,
going so far to say,
- We will never give up,
we will never concede, it doesn't happen.
And after this, we're gonna walk down,
and I'll be there with you,
but we're gonna walk down
to the Capitol
(crowd cheers)
and we're gonna cheer
on our brave senators
and congressmen and women.
And we're probably not
gonna be cheering so much
for some of them.
- Like a wannabe dictator, he said...
- Because you'll never take
back our country with weakness.
You have to show strength
and you have to be strong.
- Similarly, the
president's right-hand man,
Rudy Giuliani, demanded trial by combat.
- Let's have trial by combat.
- By both incitement and omission,
this president and his
cronies are responsible
for what happened today in
one of the worst attacks
on both our democracy and
the physical buildings
that are the manifestation
of our government,
which are not always the same thing.
But today, life imitates art.
And they did their damnedest to attack
both the idea of our democracy
and our democracy itself.
The president failed to
deploy the National Guard
or properly defend the Capitol,
both before the mob arrived
and long after it started
to attack the Capitol.
There's right now talk of
implementing the 25th Amendment,
as if his feckless cabinet
members would actually do it.
But even if they would,
that's too good for him.
If one thing is certain today,
it's that the president, Donald Trump,
needs to be impeached and removed.
And I can't help but draw an analogy to
what happened just a few
months ago in Lafayette Square.
You might recall that
the president attacked
unarmed, peaceful protestors
in a public street
just so he could get a cynical photo op
in front of a church and
hold a Bible upside down.
He was willing to employ
every military officer,
every federal employee with a gun
to move aside these people exercising
their first amendment rights
so that he could get a photo op.
And it turns out, and I have to admit,
I did not see this one coming,
that you can abuse the National Guard
and the military and the
police by deploying them
and also by withholding them,
which is what the president did today.
In the face of a violent mob
that was armed to the teeth,
the president turned a blind eye.
I'm not talking about the people
who are protesting them at all,
fine, that's your right.
We're allowed to disagree with each other.
But as they turned their
ire that was stoked
by the president himself,
the president was okay with it,
because they were on his team.
And there's a famous photo of troops
at the Lincoln Memorial in the summertime
wearing full fatigues, prepared
for just about anything.
But that wasn't the case today,
on the day that Congress was supposed
to certify the results of the election.
Because these riders were
on the president's team.
They were loved by the president.
Even as they destroyed the
government, he loved them.
And apart from the complete
lack of preparation,
there were conflicting reports
about the National Guard being deployed
at the request of the mayor of D.C.
and that it's possible that the Department
of Defense refused to allow
the D.C. National Guard
to protect the Capitol
after it was under siege.
Eventually, the National
Guard from other states
were deployed, but it's indisputable that
even they weren't deployed
except after extreme delay.
This would be comical if it
wasn't so sad and terrifying.
It's the stuff of B-movie
schlock like "White House Down,"
the kind of thing that's popcorn fodder
because it's so hilariously impossible.
And yet today in America it happened.
It didn't take a foreign
military to invade.
It took Donald Trump's
incompetence and venality.
We're going to have to have
a full investigation as to
how a moderately-sized crowd
could breach the American Capitol.
But at the moment, video appears to show
that it's possible that
Capitol or Metropolitan Police
were complicit in this mob
and allowed riders through
towards the Capitol.
And eventually, once the mob
breached the Capitol doors,
some of the cops were taking
selfies with these terrorists.
And don't tell me that the
Capitol Police are incapable
of arresting people.
I've seen Capitol police arrest disabled,
peaceful protesters before
and drag them out by their crutches.
And nationally, 14,000
people were arrested
during the George Floyd protests.
It seems impossible, but
two incendiary devices,
probably pipe bombs, were
brought to the Capitol.
Many of these people were armed.
However many arrests happen
today, it's not enough.
And let's not forget the senators
and congresspeople who
promoted this fantasy
and engaged in these conspiracy theories
because they thought it
was politically expedient.
They forgot that words have consequences.
Senators like Josh Hawley,
Ted Cruz, Ron Johnson,
Kelly Loeffler, James
Lankford, David Purdue,
Steve Daines, John
Kennedy, Marsha Blackburn,
Mike Braun, Cynthia
Lummis, Roger Marshall,
Bill Hagerty, and Tommy Tuberville.
Thankfully, some of those
people are no longer senators.
And good riddance.
As my friends at "Crew" put it,
Trump loaded the gun and
Congress pulled the trigger.
Remarkably, some of these very senators,
like Senators Hawley and Cruz,
have actually been fundraising
during the insurrection
as the mob reportedly rushed
the two chambers of Congress.
Senator Romney reportedly
excoriated Senator Cruz,
saying this was his responsibility,
that he brought this insurrection on.
And he's right.
I was watching the floor
debate this afternoon.
In his objection on the
floor of the Senate,
Senator Cruz cited statistics
about a large number
of Americans who believed
in this ridiculous conspiracy theory.
- I understand your
concerns, but I urge you
to pause and think, what does it say
to the nearly half the country
that believes this election was rigged
if we vote not even to consider the claims
of illegality and fraud in this election?
- Which is ironic because a large number
of people believe it
because people like him
promoted the ridiculous conspiracy theory.
Now, Cruz, always a cynical politician,
implied he didn't believe
it and didn't think
that we should change the
outcome of the election,
but said, "We should at least
engage in these objections.
We're just asking questions.
We can't tell them to jump in a lake."
Well, with absolutely zero
respect, Senator Cruz,
these people can jump in a
lake and never come back.
Riders stormed the
State House in Michigan,
tried to kidnap the governor,
and invaded the governor's
house in Kentucky.
All the while, certain
Republicans continued
to fan the flames.
And in the face of an impeachment,
perhaps a stronger case than in Watergate,
they still played politics.
At one point, President Trump
in the debate famously said with regard
to the racist organization the Proud Boys,
"Stand back and stand by."
- Proud boys, stand back and stand by.
- Well, they did, until today.
And to those of you who
voted for these politicians,
you knew damn well that they were snakes
when you let them in.
And all while this
insurrection was happening,
the president made it worse, saying,
- We love you, you're very special.
- Even as they are literally trying
to bring down the
government, he can't help
but praise them because he
thinks they're on his team.
His attempts to disarm
these people via tweet
or video were so laughably pathetic
that Twitter suspended
the president's account
because they were worried it
was doing more harm than good,
which is probably exactly
what the president wants.
He's not going to be president in 14 days,
so let it all burn.
If we've learned anything
from this whole affair,
it's that we absolutely have
to impeach President Trump
again, remove him from office,
and prevent him from
taking any office again.
This is a man who cannot hold power.
There are 14 days left in this presidency,
and that's far, far too long.
Who knows what kind of damage
that he can do in that time?
And the 25th Amendment, frankly,
is too good for this man.
At the very least, we can't
let him pardon the traitors
who invaded the U.S. Capitol,
let alone all of his cronies
who have done untold number
of illegal and immoral things.
On the campaign trail,
President Trump said,
"What do you have to lose?"
Well, it turns out, everything.
But we are stronger than this small man.
We are stronger than this pathetic mob.
Members of Congress are
working through the night
to certify the election,
and that's amazing.
We already voted.
We sent Donald Trump
packing, and good riddance.
We're going to rebuild the Capitol.
It's just a building.
And this is the last pathetic gasp
of the failed experiment of Trumpism.
And again, good riddance.
And thank you for showing the world
just how pathetic your movement is,
how willing to engage in violence you are,
how all of your criticisms
were in bad faith,
and how you are the worst of all of us,
how deplorable you are.
Your movement will die
an ignominious death.
And let this be a lesson.
Being a patriot doesn't mean
wearing an American flag.
It means standing up for our institutions
and fighting conspiracy theories.
So let's unmask these traitors,
let's ridicule them, let's arrest them.
And let's start with the one
that currently lives at 1600 Pennsylvania.